two-time academy award winner mahershala
ali takes his first lead role in a
feature film in swan song the story is
set in the not so distant future it
follows ali's character cameron turner
who is diagnosed with a terminal illness
and faces a big decision he can tell his
family and die leaving them to grieve
his loss or he can let a perfect clone
take his place and his family will never
know it's not him here's a preview
[Music]
molecularly regenerated
[Music]
mapped to your dna
cameron turner
to the molecule
[Music]
mahershala ali joins us right now let me
say the great rehearsal
yeah right now
i am a huge fan as we all are we've been
talking about you all morning all the
money we came into the studio
all we've been talking about yes a very
fascinating premise to this film what
drew you to it
what you just said the premise it was
it's just undeniable
fresh it wasn't something that i'd ever
seen before
and it just was filled with so much
heart and soul
and then in getting to speak with our
wonderful director benjamin cleary on
the phone and then in person
i i was i was all in i was all in it's a
special film but it's two of you you're
acting against yourself and that's the
other thing i marvel at about how
difficult that was and what that
experience was like you're talking to
yourself back and forth yeah it's
extraordinary you have a scene where you
just have one tear that falls down the
eye there's so many so many times where
you're acting without saying a word i
know that's what acting is but you did
it so beautifully look thank you so
acting against yourself tell us about
that process you know usually when it's
two people in the scene 100 of the time
when there's two people in the scene you
get to bounce off of each other and you
find the chemistry and you you get to
the scene sort of unfolds before your
eyes
and i think in in something that you
know has to be cut together with just
you in it
it requires you to play the whole scene
out in your head and make sure that
you're making the choices
that allow the scene to crescendo in the
way that it's supposed to or play out in
the way it's supposed to so i had a
wonderful collaborator uh actor by the
name of shane dean who was doubling for
me oh so i would just communicate to him
what i was trying to do in that scene
and then we would we'd he would do it
first reverse and then eventually they'd
splice things together and it worked out
well did it affect your rehearsal
because we all had the conversation what
we would do right in that situation did
this have an effect on you i'm curious
the movie had had a deep impact on me to
the point where i needed to take a
couple of months off afterwards and just
make sure
that um
that i kind of let the character
character go a bit but in terms of just
the story itself
i think i walked away from it
very aware that i can't clone myself but
what i can do is is be very present with
the people friends family loved ones now
and and make sure i'm always taking
stock and doing and taking inventory of
the voids in my life
to work to fulfill them and to live as
whole and and be moving forward in my
life as much as possible because none of
us know
when our number is going to be called
you know we showed that scene where
glenn close explains that the clone is
you down to the molecule but what we
were all talking about we were talking
about this in the green room is
whether or not your clone jack was
actually a better version of you and
what that was like as a performer
realizing that this clone was actually
probably better to you and did not go
through what you were going through you
had a terminal illness in the film i
think i think my the clone has an
advantage it does
and that he's aware that
he's aware that he has the potential to
live on without that illness right and
so right so in some ways he's the
potential of of cameron manifested yeah
like in physical form because
he's getting to take advantage of things
in ways that cameron didn't take
advantage of because like we all like we
all do
we we take life for granted we get very
comfortable in our in our space and how
we've built a world around us and we may
not push ourselves
but upon getting this sort of death
sentence or you're aware that you're
you're you're consciously aware that
your days are numbered i think different
things can kick in for people and so
jack gets to take advantage of the
awareness that
i only have so much time but he doesn't
have the same health issues as cameron
can we just talk about you for a second
rehearsal number one on the call sheet
your first lead role yes you know when
you first came out everyone how do you
say his name how you say now everybody
knows your name and knows how to almost
everything correct
correctly guys got it down yes we do
have it down so what has this journey
been like for you how are you feeling
about being mahershali and all that that
means
so from there i i feel i feel so blessed
everything happens
happens and for me my interpretation is
things happen in god's time
and sometimes we we want things when we
want them and we think we think we're
ready for them but
when i look back i don't think i was
ready for this moment and
this degree of responsibility and i feel
very very grateful that that things have
begun to happen for me and the time in
which they have because um
i feel like i can be in gratitude about
it all in a different way than what i
could have been years earlier last thing
about this movie real quick it captures
the the duality in all of us yes and
there's one person that is dealing with
the mortality of who he is and another
person has a very optimistic view on the
world
what advice would you give to
individuals out there that might be
dealing with two versions of themselves
and are
grappling with the idea of being better
take advantage
take advantage of this moment
and work towards your fulfillment
listen to that voice that call and
response that is telling you to
to let something go and move towards
something else yeah which is always
going to ask you to do something
difficult like say yes to the things
that are difficult say yes to the fear
lean in on it and continue to push
yourself so that
we can all die in motion you know nobody
wants to die in neutral you know we're
all going to go so die in motion dying
in motion
can i just say get ready for your oscar
there we go
i can't wait to see what you guys wear
ali thank you so much swan song is an
incredible movie it's out in theaters
and on apple tv plus december 17th diane
thank the best of the year thank you for
having me bravo